ecuador sobrepasa los niveles de
contagios en 300% en comparación a la
semana anterior correspondiente del 9 al
15 de enero significa el nivel de
contagios más altos en el país andino
desde el inicio de la pandemia ante la
circulación de la variante o micro la
positividad también se incrementó en la
segunda semana del mes en curso de
presente año del 10 al 46 por ciento
donde la mayoría de los contagios se
encuentra en la provincia costera de
guayas donde se inició la pandemia en
este país a pesar del incremento de la
cifra con libres de mortalidad son
menores debido a la vacunación según
cifras oficiales el ejecutivo activó un
plan de protección sanitaria dividido en
verde amarillo y rojo según las
actividades diferenciados por cantones
en la mayor parte del país para contener
la ocupación hospitalaria donde 56% de
las camas se encuentran ocupadas y 84%
de las unidades de cuidados intensivos
en demanda 70% de los pacientes que
llegan lo hacen sin su ciclo de
vacunación completo durante una semana
el gobierno ha anunciado una serie de
medidas que corresponden la suspensión
de clases a nivel educativo en 193 de
los 221 cantones del país las
actividades públicas y los servicios no
esenciales
reducen según su riesgo salir del
supermercado ir a entidades financieras
a asistir la educación entre otros será
regulado por niveles de riesgo para
reducir los voluntarios y la movilidad
en el país la preocupación se centra
ahora en los casos de contagios en los
niños menores de 18 años afirmaron las
autoridades por ello se recomienda
limitar la suprema las aglomeraciones a
pesar de ello el ejecutivo nacional ha
dicho que no confieren a nuevamente a la
ciudadanía